no no no no no non lo fare e non fare
loro fare l'affare ora che sta roba ti
dei punti a sono saltati in aria di
brutto
e allora quanto hanno fatto e
straordinaria te lo giuro
[Musica]
ok ho vinto vinto vinto ho vinto così
facendo sai cagando nei cespugli
riguardo al culo [ __ ] lo sapevo
che doveva uscire qualcosa
lo sapevo ne dall'inizio sapevo che
sarebbe uscito un cristiano a correre
allora questa incazzata già si è
svegliata male questa la faccia vedova
che incazzata che è il tipo dietro ei
bel maschione sono velociraptor sì ma
non ha letto
devo capire ragazzi se riesco a presto
ma cos'è ma cosa fa perché ora questo
nome correa si è sempre ancora di come
pingu te lo dico io e muori come pingu
hai solo pochi secondi per scappare alla
mia trappola c'è solo un modo per
scappare se non scappi prima del tempo
morirai tanti auguri solo perfetto
quanto tempo è una domanda che non
necessita più di risposta ragazzini
abbiamo capito che la tipa decide lei
quando comparirebbe tipo adesso
[ __ ]
come faccio a mandare un toast sopra al
tostapane non ci arriva neanche il cane
avea era così potente zio
nick ha trovato gli arti 9 gli artigli
nascosti nel cassetto giusto bello ce
l'ho anch'io nascosto io ci affetto la
bistecca con quelle ve ne frega un cazzo
a lui l'aveva benefici a rock
adesso credo che gli e freghi un foglio
il tratto è diventato sushi
bene fa vj che si appresta a tirare in
porta fa vige odio posso fare il salto
best salto ever scorre zio se non corri
sei morto come dico ma che cazzo sei
spider man forte a [ __ ] core
deciditi puoi parlare italiano inglese
piano ma non sei neanche depilata
[Musica]
pesaro
visse model già stai a bari o aiuto ce
so
6 sono morto dentro fi gente che come
tutti i ragazzi di vent'anni passa le
giornate a rimorchiare le tipe perché
questo che i ragazzi di 20 anni fanno o
forse no non mi rincorreva così cose
chiama uncle prof
doveva fare le verifiche questo è
svenuto questi giocano a pagina stelle
vite parallele
beh non è che casca antica mette un paio
d'occhiali per cortesia storta zia
capiamoci io fa vj lei e rosita tutte e
due siamo pacifici è quindi calma ci
vuole calma
oddio oddio come è rimasto on up e le
gare play e andiamo a dare un'occhiata
andiamo a dare un'occhiata se ne va con
il piccolo charlie anch'io chelsea no
non devi dargli da mangiare quello
quello sempre per infilarlo su per il
culo
oh cazzo se va a pezzi o o mio dio
cos'era va male
[Musica]
questa cosa non l'ho capito oddio
attento vai che via via vieni via che
cela di debito via terra via
[Musica]
ci spetta i ragazzi mi ricordo addio
buon san valentino palo
salve sono un cliente volevo sapere cosa
cosa vendete sono un cliente salve
giorno mi scusi lei che ci sta girando
mi dà una mano per colpire ecco perfetta
e continua a svenire sulla panchina io
non ho parole ragazza
[Musica]
se su wikipedia cerchio youtuber
incredibilmente intelligente c'è la mia
faccia non c'è qua crepaccio gaga dammi
la mano canta qualcosa si deve morire
male lo sai vero
qui c'è già la mannaia ragazzi perché
incazzato nero è nero quindi incazzato
nero è un pene ho trovato capitava porca
[ __ ] cosa è successo
oddio è uscito l'altro tasto a caso ci
sarebbe bello web e cloud 6 moriremo
tutti ma che cazzo succede
tutti e tre sono primo e sto accadendo
il giorno dopo il diamante della minkia
i tre scali nel lavandino lobuli dato no
perché tutti gli amanti della vicenda
però però lo capisco effettivamente
perché a trovarne di diamanti su
minecraft io farei così tra l'altro
posso farti una domanda giusto perché
capire cioè nel lavandino ci hai un
frullatore che cazzo di lavandino è è un
cupido ubriachi stimolante sverso gente
basta una birra la parte veramente
l'impossibilità fatta videogioco
un grande abbraccio
al 13 buona
ciao zio capisci anche tualis adattati
da gente comunque a senti se vogliamo
giocare aa.vv 7 gioca con mio cugino che
c'ha tre anni
nell'anno scassa ducati ei papi e appena
sfruttato un di briganti in centro città
che vuole utilizzarlo prima che lo
facciano gli altri ti conviene darti una
mossa l'hanno visto dove farà ritorno
prima che si possa dire va via mi stava
facendo il telefono
ora il fisico che hai sempre desiderato
ma avrai la faccia di nicolas cage è
bellissimo ecco questa si chiama arte
avete presente l'arte questa è arte la
seguente l'opera d'arte ladies quartet e
di famiglie esposta il libro evante un
valore di 4 milioni di dollari cioè la
linea amica mia cioè ci sentiamo alla
prossima porca put smembra seriamente
cosa ma cosa ma come ma cos'è sta roba
seria venda magra come contenta di
essere smembrata se l'impresa testa
peperonata strada vento mi stava dentro
lo sento sento cose babbo natale che vi
chiedo che babbo natale non è fatta per
fare qualcos'altro faccio cadere le
forbici e tanto posso capirlo che natale
è passato ma non è che devi fare per
forza il cosplay di gesù cioè calmati
zio viene prodotto vieni vieni a
prendermi curtis parte tutte le ruote
della macchina vieni è serio ciao sono
una tipa e cioè dopo a qualcuno che mi
dia una mano porca eva solo una donzella
sono una donzella ambiente la fine non
interessa più a nessuno quando si affoga
nessuno guarda in faccia nessuno
chiamerò la policiano 6 la polizia e
vabbé ma tutti corrotti del cazzo morite
io e mio foto idrante conquisteremo il
mondo ora che sono arrivato fin qua ci
ho messo un anno
se sbaglio la mira non ce la farò mai
più
[Musica]
e quindi ragazzi questa speciale due
milioni e mezzo di iscritti oria vi
ringrazio davvero di cuore veramente
cioè quando siamo arrivati a 2 milioni
era già un qualcosa di non pensavo mai
di arrivare a due milioni elezioni
grazie anche a due milioni e mettila
tanto che sono anche di arrivare a mille
sta faccia capo niente ragazzi vi
ringrazio davvero di cuore e anche per i
montando questi speciali qua
ripercorrendo tutto quello che ho fatto
nell'ultimo anno mi rendo conto del
percorso che che si evolve ogni volta e
sempre più bello vedere come insieme
riusciamo a crescere quindi ragazzi vi
ringrazio per questo traguardo
incredibile se mai dovesse arrivare un
altro vi ringrazierà di nuovo quindi non
può il carso questi ringraziamenti me
squilla il telefono
non mi ricordo che eravamo rimasti
perché il telefono ma sfasato tutto il
discorso da presidente però niente
ragazzi io spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che questo caso sia perché
continua a essere nei miei video star o
che cosa i ragazzi servizio è piaciuto
lasciato argomento è un mi piace tanto
la pace di facebook come antidoto tale
descrizione ma mi assalgono i pupazzi
porca eva senza visti indiscrezioni ci
vediamo prossimo vinto